it seems to me that there are two kinds
of problems that comprehensive digital
memory that poses to us the first one
I'd like to label power problems for
power challenges it usually has to do
with the fact that when we share
information with somebody else that
person has some informational power over
us that that person can use in order to
sell us some stuff to market us some
stuff and that information can be
aggregated can be shared with others so
that the certain informational profile
can arise about us this is what has been
the focal point of information privacy
research for a very long period of time
but I believe this kind of dyadic
relationship if you want between our
person the data subject that gives
information and the processor that
receives information it's only part of
the picture we need to go beyond this
relatively small scale view particularly
when we look at the importance of memory
let me give you an example for a very
long period of time we thought that
sharing stuff on the internet is
somewhat dangerous because it's not just
our friends that have access to it but
it's everybody around the world that has
access to it hundreds of millions of
people and thousands of jurisdictions
and somebody somewhere might actually be
offended by what we had to say and I
might get a court to agree and then we
find ourselves having to defend our
actions much like the Google managers
had to do a few weeks back when they
were successfully sued and convicted in
a Italian court for what they did or
didn't do on YouTube and and so that's
been around that view has been around
for a couple of years it's called the
panopticon the panopticon basically is
an idea that has been with us for a
hundred and some years invented by
Jeremy Bentham and Britain the idea is
it would be great to create a prism in
which the prisoners don't know when the
prison guards watch them they have to
assume that they're always watched and
therefore they have to behave all the
time similarly because we don't know who
is watching us online we have to behave
all the time
to the lowest common denominator and
therefore our behavior is skewed as
constrained and many people have been
writing about that but I believe there
is with digital memory something much
more problematic coming up and that has
to do with the longevity of digital
memory so we have to face the fact that
what we say and do online today will not
only be viewed by the hundreds of
millions of people that are online today
but might be viewed and interpreted
differently by people and institutions
ten years 20 or 30 years down the road
when we're no longer young and we might
not be as engaged in public discourse
and protest anymore but we might want to
apply for a well paid investment bankers
job and then they might just Google us
and find out at 15 years earlier we said
something that wasn't so complementary
to the banks or so so therefore a
comprehensive digital memory creates
what I call a temporal panopticon it
creates a situation in which we have to
fear that we are not only watched today
but we are watched by future generations
by our future and that really
dramatically constrains what we ought to
do online and pushes us towards
self-censorship exactly when we don't
need self-censorship because we need
robust public debate online that's what
online discourse is all about
well let me give you an example of what
happens already today so there's people
who lose their jobs who relationships
blow up basically because of what they
said online earlier on but there are
also cases that are quite shocking in a
way I had a woman call in at one of the
radio shows that I did and she told me
about her case she had been convicted of
a crime in the state of California many
years ago when she was 17 years served
in prison then was released started a
new life went to a new place found the
husband had kids started a family
basically everything was was an order
she even found God so hey this sounds
like a happy end story except one day a
colleague of her son in school googled
her and found the website of mug shots
of all prison inmates in California over
the last 20 or 25 years and she was
right in there and suddenly the
community her small community that she
lived and knew that she actually was an
ex-convict and immediately ostracized
her and her new life unraveled and she
called in said what can I do and I said
nothing this isn't this is the
unfortunate side effect of a digital
memory that doesn't forget while our
society forgets we forgive even
ex-convict but the digital memory
doesn't do that anymore